le klan pendant la première
année ou plus d'un an était simplement
un groupe qui était un groupe social et en tant que
groupe social,
ils ont développé des rituels euh ils ont développé des
rituels mystiques élaborés qui venaient de
rituels de fraternité ils venaient de
rituels maçonniques
[Musique]
donc
les gens ont  a eu l'idée que le klu
klux klan n'est qu'une organisation anti-nègre,
c'est que cette organisation n'est donc pas
anti-nègre, anti-juive ou anti-catholique,
nous sommes pro-américains
[Musique]
il ne fait aucun doute dans l'esprit de quiconque
que l'influence communiste  est dans
le mouvement des droits civiques ou pas mesdames
et messieurs il n'y a aucun doute là-dessus il n'y
a aucun doute dans l'esprit de quiconque a
assassiné notre président des
états-unis
un communiste mesdames et messieurs
depuis que vous avez demandé je déteste les noirs je déteste les
juifs les
mexicains et les irlandais les italiens et les chinois
mais ma bouche aux oreilles de Dieu, je déteste vraiment
ces rats noirs
et tous ceux qui n'ont pas vraiment de
sang aryen blanc pur qui coule dans
leurs veines
[Musique]
nous voulions connecter un film
qui est une pièce d'époque du début des années 70 avec
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui dans  le monde a
récemment deux jeunes frères ont été lynchés
dans plus d'Oklahoma et j'aime dire cela
parce que les gens en parlaient, ils
n'étaient
pas lynchés, vous n'avez pas besoin
d'être pendu à un arbre
pour être lynché c'est 2018. absolument
états-unis d'amérique
[musique]
vous